you don't do a lot of podcasts huh
no actually i've been asked to do many
podcasts and
especially this one tim dillon i don't
know if you know tim dillon sure he's on
fire
he's he's one of my favorite podcasts
and he asked me months ago like
he's my favorite podcast he asked me
like yo can you please come on podcast
i'm like no
because i uh i'm not the best talker and
i feel like i
may or not may or may not have autism
and that's how i feel
i mean dude you're uh you seem to be
talking great with me
man and uh i think that your
your career is evident you know
you felt like you needed to drink to do
a podcast yeah i do because i have uh
i feel like i have autism i i may or may
not i mean
why do you feel like you have autism
because i feel like um
i feel like i'm i'm very dumb but at the
same time i'm the
i i always call myself i always call
myself this i'm the
the dumbest genius in the world all
right
because it's it's a fact that people who
think they're smart
are the dumber people yeah and actually
smart people think they're dumb
yeah so i actually think i'm the
stupidest person in the world but at the
same time i have
something special in this autism brain
of mine can i just tell you how
[ __ ] up my new tour is it's completely
multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because
it's gnarly and it's all the stuff i
wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats